there have been conversations about
inventing new kinds of weapons
similar you know projectile weapons
smokeless powder-based but using things
other than primers other than hammers
maybe uh uh you know electrical charge
or there's also directed energy weapons
and the issue is will will the language
of law have to become so vague
that it's an inversion of the second
amendment because
i bring up the the household chemicals
right there's also household appliances
that can be turned into some seriously
devastating weapons
household appliances you watch these
videos on youtube man you'll be like i
don't know i can do that with one of
those things and you'll be like
yeah and i mean people can easily make
some pretty powerful and devastating
weapons that
could theoretically be more dangerous
depending on the context or even worse
you know a simple question would rather
get shot or set on fire
and have you know second degree burns
all over your body
there's some serious questions about
that because the long-term damage to
skin
is is devastating so when you look at
what's available in the home for people
to use as weapons i suppose the argument
is
yeah but people if they don't know how
to do it or need you know it's some kind
of labor then it's easy to pick up a gun
and just use
i guess the ultimate issue is we're
dealing with 3d printed weapons
we're dealing with new kinds of direct
energy weapon technology that you can't
even see infrared lasers for instance or
microwave
technology what are they going to do are
they going to pass a law saying
the transmission of any kind of energy
object material
mass or or other uh
substance structure or otherwise
that is emitted from one point from near
one person by their control
and and makes contact with another
person and by means causes a negative
impact would be considered a crime like
does the law have to get to that point
sure i mean that's basically an argument
that i gave to somebody about ar15s i
said
you know the minute that elon musk
invents
a solar-powered laser rifle with
unlimited
ammo uh i'm gonna want one of those too
because that
sounds a whole hell of a lot better than
an ar-15 and so
if you know that's eventually maybe not
exactly that but
that's eventually going to happen like
the pace of technology i mean as we know
you look at um you know internet
technology that i mean
it outpaces the ability for government
to regulate
what is being invented and that's really
what we're talking about here is
you know how do we regulate human
innovation
and effectively that's what the second
that's what that's what
people on the left are trying to do with
the second amendment and
they've just unfortunately we've allowed
them to be successful in some manner
so uh one of the biggest challenges with
directed energy weapons
say a massive extremely high-powered
infrared laser which you can't see
can be pointed at someone or something
and set them on fire or burn holes
through structures
they've done naval demonstrations where
they have a drone flying
and they point this massive infrared
laser and it just instantly hits it it's
a speed of light
and the drum bursts into flames then
goes down and crashes one of the biggest
challenges
is the amount of energy required for
that with firearms
that energy is stored very simply as
chemical energy in a cartridge
and then it's focused through the barrel
with some rifling you get a spin you get
better accuracy it converts that energy
wonderfully directed energy weapons
waste a lot of energy
but in gravity exactly
super super capacitor we're like what
half an hour in we haven't even talked
about graphics well so so
i bring this up because ian you often
talk about graphene technology
how it's going to be revolutionary and
you're right but don't you think they're
going to weaponize it yeah they're going
to use fusion pack
power with graphene super capacitors
they'll stir the charge and they'll be
setting stuff on fire from 600 yards so
what what happens then when some kid
finds his dad's graphene fusion pack ir
blaster
and he puts it on his backpack and then
he's holding this like long
you know tube and then he just points it
at people and then
some kids goes and then bursts into
flames and they're just pointing and
sweeping across
and no one knows where it's coming from
it's just all these kids and bursting
into flames
and then he walks away no one knows what
happened that's horrifying to think of
but the problem with these laws is that
they don't stop that
like you you've mentioned this before 3d
printing it's out the cat's out of the
bag i know dude
i'm concerned with with weapons of mass
destruction even though that's a vague
term like how do you define
and if you guys know legally how do you
define a weapon of mass destruction
you know i'm not sure i don't i don't
know when i think of like
lasers or bullets that's like a kid
or guy worst case scenario takes out 100
people
maybe 120 people that's not to me really
mass destruction i think of like
leveling buildings and blocks it says
killing numerous people and leveling
buildings but there's no real
it's vague six people could be numerous
um
that's what i'm concerned with is mass
destruction like the ability to wipe out
cities
villages towns families if we give that
power
to a dad that can forget and leave it
out for his kid to pick up
then i start to get nervous i mean i i
look at the judgment of some of our
politicians and
i get nervous i don't care if it's true
it's biden and the whole reason we're
here is because the second amendment man
i mean it's the it's basically because
they armed themselves and were able to
overthrow a dictatorial monarchy
that doesn't explain other countries a
lot of countries have
have have these weapons a lot of these
countries have
you know desperate lunatics who are
armed to the teeth north korea is
building nukes
the benefit for the second amendment is
actually great and we're lucky the
united states exists in fact because
it's probably a deterrent
that the famous quote you can't invade
america behind every blade of grass
i don't know that's a real quote i think
it might be like it's not apocryphal
but but it's true and now we've got
millions new
millions of new gun owners so it's 20
million 20 million 20 million that's
that's the rough estimate that we know
of
new york registered gun owners and then
the 3d printing craze and i i just wrote
an article
maybe i should have brought it with me
uh that i think 3d printing guns has
taken like an evolutionary leap in the
last year
yeah the technology is getting much much
better
3d printing technology is coming down in
price and
the materials that they can print with
are getting much better
metal 3d printing is already available
the price point is more than what a
consumer can afford but
i mean things are only going to get
better
over time the technology is going to get
smaller it's going to get cheaper
so i mean the government is already
behind the power curve in in that way
well it so you think it's just a matter
of
you know how how bold people get about
telling the government no more or less
so i mean if you
if you have the 3d printing gun
community that says hey look we're just
going to 3d print guns
and we're going to tell everybody that
this is what we're doing and we're going
to dare the government to tell us to
stop
i mean that's really when you get to the
point where
decisions have to be made more or less i
mean
technology for uh home manufacturing is
getting better and better and better
it's not going to stop they're going to
have to ban home
milling machines you know people who
have cnc machines at their home i i know
a guy
who had a a relatively small machining
a cnc machine for metal parts and he
could
just take blocks of metal and cut them
very easily in a small little building
he owned
yeah i mean this this idea that like
manufacturing firearms at home is
something new
or that the government never conceived
that we have to deal with is
is just so silly because i mean in the
in the in the 18th century that's how
you made a firearm i mean
you you more or less had to either build
it yourself or
you had i mean that's where the term
lock stock and barrel comes from you had
a metal smith that made the the lock
the the flintlock mechanism you had a
craftsman who made the the stock and
then you had
another uh metal smith who made the
barrel and
they put all those pieces together and
so your firearm
uh if it broke you couldn't just take
parts from your buddy's firearm to fix
it because
they probably wouldn't fit they'd be
different size different shape i mean
that was
that was the big thing that samuel colt
brought to the table
you know people credit henry ford for
the production line and mass
manufacturing but
interchangeable parts it was really
samuel colt who did that
he he modernized manufacture
he modernized manufacturing and got to
the point of interchangeable parts
and and mass production uh there's a
story i don't know if it's true if it's
colloquial but
that he was i believe it was the uh i
can't remember what government he was
trying to sell his uh revolvers to a
foreign country and so he he went there
and as part of the demonstration he put
out a number of the revolvers on the
table
he fired them all to show that they
worked and then he took them all apart
and he put all the parts in a box and
mixed all the parts together and then he
reassembled all the revolvers
you know obviously with parts from other
revolvers so you couldn't tell what was
what
and then he fired them all again to show
that they worked
and everybody was just could not believe
that that was possible that all the
parts would work
in the other firearms and uh
that was kind of the birth of you know
mass manufacturing
interchangeable parts and that was to
the point
it was it was in the area where tooling
and
manufacturing techniques were getting to
the point where they were precise enough
to
allow that to happen so now it looks
like we're in the next
phase of that with 3d printing you can
print the actual parts on demand in your
house
sure okay so it's it wouldn't be the
replaceable part revolution but the
i don't know what your home
manufacturing whole manufacturing right
yep exactly
making home manufacturing low skill
right
low skill and i mean i know i know all
kinds of cnc machinists that can make a
firearm
with the machines that they have no
problem but
the idea is making it easy i mean
i i was interested in the 80 percent
lower
community you know years ago so
basically you can buy what's called an
80
lower receiver for an ar-15 and what
that means is
it has some of the machining operations
are not been completed
so it's not considered a firearm it's
basically just a block of metal it's not
serialized you can purchase one right
off the internet and ship it to your
home it's not a firearm
so there is a community of people who
are who are machining these
into a finished receiver and at first
the techniques were pretty rudimentary
you you bought a jig and you basically
did it with a drill press you just
machined out everything one hole at a
time
and they were kind of crude and messy i
mean they worked but
they weren't all that great and then
defense distributed made the ghost
gunner cnc
and so it's a small cnc machine about
the size of a microwave
and you put your lower receiver in there
in a jig and you press the button you
walk away and a few hours later all the
machining is done and it's perfect and
and you don't have the rights are sharp
you don't got to register that or no it
doesn't have to be registered doesn't
have to be serialized
if you're manufacturing it for your
personal use you can't sell it because
it doesn't have a serial number
but you can make them for your own
purposes
so that was kind of the first iteration
and you know that
the ghost gunner costs about two
thousand dollars so it's not like it's
but this is super cheap but the point is
it made home manufacturing much easier
much more precise set it and forget it
and and that was kind of the first
but you still have state laws right you
still have at this at the state level
you can't have certain weapons sure yeah
very ev every state is a little bit
different
um so you you have to figure out what's
legal in your state i mean in new jersey
i i know that they don't allow 80
receivers uh there's other states i i
don't know them all off the top of my
head but
that i mean that's a big problem in and
of itself is the laws
are so convoluted and they basically
are just a number of of traps more or
less so
you know you can assemble a firearm
totally innocently
and make something that
is illegal without you really have to
know the law before you start putting
things to together that are outside of
sort of the standard configuration and
if you're building it you could invent
something new
right now this is the ultimately the
bigger issue with everything is
there's just invention you know
someone's going to come up with
something it's not going to be regulated
designer weapons right and that's and
that's a problem too is um
because the laws are so convoluted and
because
you have to get a federal firearms
license etc to do certain things
sot license it stifled innovation
so if you're if you're a hobbyist
gunsmith and you have a really good idea
for a new type of machine gun that you
think is
very important something let's say that
you you think this machine gun could
revolutionize the us military and you
really want to design this thing on your
own you want to patent it on your own
but you don't have a federal firearms
license you know you're you're going to
be committing a felony very
quickly so unless you get a boat and go
out to international waters to do it
there you go okay building islands with
uh john mcafee you
get on his boat and yeah i i heard that
there was a bunch of these ultra wealthy
individuals we're gonna buy a cruise
ship
just park it right off of international
waters they can do whatever they wanted
it's iron rand
yeah yeah the chinese are building
islands that's an interesting thing or
you can go to china china will let you
do it
you could walk in and be like hey you
want bullets they'd be like good do it
so i my concern here now is that trying
to regulate
the home industry is insanity it is that
if you try to make it illegal for
someone to do what they're doing
you're just creating criminals and it's
not going to stop
it might stop some of them but it won't
stop the innovation itself you know
look early on in the united states we
greatly prospered because
crazy people did crazy things out in the
middle of nowhere
you had uh mary curie's papers are all
radioactive
yeah you can't do that these days you
you get anywhere near trying to do that
kind of research
they're going to lock you up there was
some dude who was obsessed with that i
write this story
where he was like a young guy and he's
taking smoke alarms because they had a
little bit of that happen in commerce
township
about america ten minutes from my house
oh really yep
yeah yeah in michigan and he kept taking
little bits and then he put it
into i think he had like a lead cap he
built a breeder reactor in his in his uh
in his shed and he really irradiated the
town basically
yeah he i think he raided the shed and
his house
uh but yeah he was he was he created a
death beast he's basically just
and there's a i want to say there's a
book or a or a movie about it it's
called the radioactive boy scout
and yeah so he was getting these smoke
alarms and there's a small amount of
radioactive material
in there and he basically collected
enough of it that he could create a pile
that would
uh become yeah had like this casing
with a a funneling channel so he could
fire
the particles and the death beam yeah
and he was covered in lesions
yeah whoa yeah he was very yeah i don't
i don't know if he's still alive i
he may have uh did you ever hear the
story this is a brief aside of the guy
who studied the first atomic bomb and
touched it on accident
he dropped it on it on his head and then
it like sent a super
shock to his body he was like ow what
happened two hours later what happened
was
the demon core yeah and they would and
they would hold it separated from
critical mass with a screwdriver
and then one day it dropped it and it
flashed and then he picked it up but it
was too late
the flash had he died destroyed i think
he made contact with something physical
contact and it shot through him like
instead of electricity though it was
like a deep penetrating radioactive
pulse through his body well i don't know
who that guy is but we gotta find that
someday
the demon core is killed like there's
been like three or four incidents with
that same core
uh where people almost created uh they
were holding a screwdriver between it to
stop between the two halves
they would twist it and get it close and
then it dropped and
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time